I'm not gonna lie in the first 30
minutes of this movie this movie made me
feel like I drank all the milk and ate
the whole sandwich if you get that
reference that means you watched the
movie and didn't listen to my review
what's wrong with you suburbicon so
suburbicon is a 1950s I believe is the
50s and 60s I'm gonna say 50 dark
comedies very suburban very American
dream Stepford Wives I mean like in an
atmosphere and tone it's this idealistic
version of the American Dream for some
people less so for people more 10 and me
long story short these guys who were
apparently mobsters of some sort are in
Matt Damon's house his wife dies after
that there's a bit of a mystery element
to it tell us what comedy element to it
island of racial commentary a social
piece somewhere woven into this movie
all of it tries to be a thing none of it
really works the movies directed by
George Clooney which if you look at
George Clooney's track record in
directing not exactly it's written by
the Coen brothers and George Clooney it
has like four writing credits in this
thing which it looks like it looks like
four different people have their thing
that they wanted to be a movie and just
got crushed into ones like here you go
make a movie out of that homely uneven
doesn't always work together whatever
funny thing is if someone tells you the
plot of this movie feel like if I were
to tell you the plot of this movie in
about 30 seconds spoilers at all be a
pretty good idea be like that sounds
like it'd be a good movie so that's me
not knocking the idea this movie is a
good idea such is the case with nine out
of ten shitty movies it's all about
execution man that's where it fails it
was a mystery a comedy a dark comedy
which is fine to have dark comedy the
Coen brothers are no strangers to that
but it has to mix it has to work you
can't have the comedy override the
moments of drama there were a couple
parts in this movie where something
happened the audience was laughing I was
left there going I don't think we were
supposed to laugh at that I think that
was supposed to be a moment or it wasn't
or they were supposed to laugh at it
point is the movies is kind of 50/50
could go one way could go the other
sometimes it works sometimes it didn't
among a movie we're in this 1950s utopic
suburban neighborhood that is
illustrated as such to a comedic degree
and over-the-top degree there's the
social commentary about rioters really
getting pissed if this black family
moved in in this neighborhood but I feel
like that was supposed to be its own
movie it wasn't really fleshed out and
they just stuck it in this movie
somewhere it feels like an afterthought
that was thrown into this movie like
on twitter somewhere that if you address
racism in a plotline somewhere even if
it has anything to do with the overall
plot or not it tracks really well with
audiences so let's do that I'd like to
think that's not the case that life pink
it's a little more pure in the world
where I'm gonna put my tinfoil hat on
for a second it just looks like
I mean the set up of this movie this
black family moving into this
neighborhood is a big deal you throw a
town meeting everyone's pizzle so you're
like okay that's the main plot of the
movie because we're here to establish
the main plot of the movie and really
it's just kind of background noise to
the main plot which means to set up
waste at its time or at least give you
the wrong information to assess the rest
of the movie everyone in the movie did
fine for the role in the movie Matt
Damon did a good job the kid did a good
job Oscar Isaac is hands-down the best
character in the movie the moment he
showed up on screen I was like movie
just got better
maybe he's that good maybe I'm man
crushing I don't know all I know is he
picked this movie up for the first time
I was like uh all right something's
happening woke me right up really this
movie's the mantra of most movies I've
reviewed lately a couple of exceptions
aside the word I generally use to
describe movies at least lately is
boring this movie was boring in the end
the movie was a good concept
I like the exaggerated tone if they
stuck with it if they committed if it
made it a comedy that worked or a dark
comedy that mix in the end it's a
muddled wreck that really just gives you
mixed signals it's about three movies
wrapped into one when the movie ended I
was like I just wasted my time and I'm
not gonna remember suburbicon and
t-minus one day yep already forgot all
right guys so suburbicon have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]